lorsque nous étions enfants il
semblerait que chacun de nous à peu près
chacun d'entre nous ayant un moment de
notre enfance donc rêver des trésors
archéologiques de l'egypte des pharaons
je pense évidemment au masque en or
massif du pharaon toutankhamon
sans parler évidemment des 250 kilos
d'or qui constituent le reste de son
fabuleux trésor funéraire également le
buste de la sublime défaire city dont la
parfaite beauté et continue à nous
fascinait même si cette belle reine a
perdu l'un de ses deux yeux dans
l'histoire et au sommet de tous ses
fantasmes que l'egypte pharaonique a
suscité dans notre chef dans notre
imaginaire collectif occidental bien
entendu le mister qui auréole la
construction des pyramides de l'ancienne
egypte tous ces objets culturels que
vous venez de voir vous les connaissez
tous vous les avez tous reconnus parce
qu'en fait ils font partie de notre
imaginaire collectif occidental depuis
notre plus tendre enfance
c'est donc durant l'enfance évidemment
que pour ma part j'ai été contaminé
oui je pense que c'est vraiment le mot
littéralement contaminés par cette
maladie qu'on appelle l'egypte à philly
la passion pour l'egypte antique et même
sous une forme particulièrement
virulente l'égyptologie qu est une
maladie aux dires des spécialistes qui
est particulièrement contagieuse donc
faites attention et dont on ne peut
jamais guérir complètement
et donc très rapidement dans mon
existence devenir égyptologue s'est
imposé comme une sorte d'évidence et
j'ai eu la chance extraordinaire
certes je le mesure chaque jour la
chance de pouvoir continuer à vivre mon
rêve d'enfance dans ma pratique
quotidienne en devenant égyptologues
alors aujourd'hui je ne vais pas vous
parler d'eux lors de toutankhamon de la
beauté parfaite de néfertiti je n'en ai
pas le temps mais je voudrais vous
inviter à faire en voyage puisque c'est
le thème du voyage aujourd'hui un voyage
non pas tant dans l'espace mais dans le
temps dans le passé dans le passé de
votre enfance mais aussi dans le passé
des pharaons pour remonter il y à peu
près cinq millénaires à l'époque où ces
monuments fabuleux ont été construits
parce que je voudrais vous montrer deux
choses la première c'est que il est
aujourd'hui possible grâce à
l'archéologie la discipline que je
pratique qui consiste à étudier
traces matérielles du comportement
humain il est possible grâce à
l'archéologie de résoudre cet apparent
mystère qui auréole la construction des
pyramides et deuxièmement je voudrais
vous montrer que l'idée même de
construire ces pyramides constitue un
élément précurseur une sorte de guide et
moonshot avant la lettre avant même
qu'on invente le concept un de ses unes
de ses idées folles qui a littéralement
changé le monde
donc les pyramides en tant qu'idée
moonshot alors je sais les faits facile
mais je n'ai pas pu résister à vous
montrer des pyramides du plateau de kisa
sous un rayon de clair de lune
évidemment les pyramides ont un effet un
impact tout à fait manifeste dans
l'histoire elles ont été copiés dès
l'antiquité ils ont été copiés par les
nubiens ont été copiés également par les
romains avec cette pyramide de cailloux
cestus cents magistrats romains qui
s'est fait enterrer dans la partie sud
de rome donc si vous allez à rome vous
pouvez voir cette pyramide sur le
territoire européen et il faut savoir
quelle est elle faisait partie des
manuels d'architecturé à l'aube de la
modernité des manuels d'architecturé d
architecte de la renaissance
donc elles sont bien connues c'est une
vieille histoire les pyramides dans
l'imaginaire collectif occidental
ce n'est pas pour rien évidemment
qu'elles sont si présents dans notre
architecture funéraire bien entendu mais
aussi dans notre architecture domestique
dans notre architecture public comme ici
dans la cour carrée du louvre évidemment
et parfois aussi dans cette architecture
public sous des formes un peu kitsch
comme à l'entrée du louxor hôtel à las
vegas mais chaque fois vous voyez il
subsiste une référence tout à fait
explicites à l'ancienne égypte alors la
fascination que suscite ces monuments
est en réalité très très ancienne leur
impact est très ancien mais la
fascination qui suscite est très ancien
et je prendrai pour l'illustrer en fait
le cas de khéops qui est vous le savez
tous vous avez tous entendu son nom
l'auteur l'initiateur de la plus grande
de ces pyramides qui culmine à
pratiquement 150 mètres de hauteur qui a
fait réaliser cette véritable montagne
de pierre artificiel eh bien on constate
que kheops quelques générations après
son décès a commencé à pâtir où près de
ses contemporains des anciens égyptiens
eux-mêmes
d'une réputation assez peu enviable
devenant à leurs yeux un souverain qui
faisait peu de cas de la vie humaine et
quittait en quelque sorte un oppresseur
c'est comme ça qu'ils devaient être
qualifiés dans ces légendes
alors cette impression que les égyptiens
vont générer à partir du personnage
historique de khéops n'est pas temps
nourri par la perception qu'ils ont eues
de son rang qui aurait été un règne
particulièrement pressant nous n'avons
aucun indice qui va dans ce sens mais
tout simplement ce pharaon khéops les
égyptiens ont réagi exactement comme
nous à l'heure actuelle face à ces
montagnes de pierre en se disant pour
réaliser un truc aussi délirant il faut
nécessairement être un dictateur
égocentrique narcissique et complètement
givrée et donc les égyptiens ont
commencé à nourrir une série de légendes
autour de la personnalité de khéops dont
hérodote le père de l'histoire s'est
fait l'écho et nous les a transmis dans
notre imaginaire collectif occidental
alors la question qui intrigue depuis
des millénaires sait donc comment
comment at il été possible de réaliser
de tels géants de pierre et même comment
at il été possible d'imaginer
s'embarquer dans un projet aussi fou
aussi gigantesque oserais-je dire aussi
pharaonique pour répondre à cette
question il faut remonter encore un
siècle plus haut dans le temps un look
du 27e siècle avant notre ère au début
de la grande période de gloire de
l'histoire égyptienne la première grand
période au beurre d'histoire égyptienne
qu'on appelle l'ancien empire avec le
règne du pharaon djoser qui est
l'initiateur de la première pyramide de
l'histoire de l'humanité qui a un impact
vous allez le voir absolument
phénoménale alors si j'ose arrête un
initiateur c'est un inventeur il
s'inscrit comme tout inventeur dans la
continuité d'une longue tradition une
tradition millénaire
une tradition qui consiste à inhumer les
grands de la civilisation égyptienne
dans des fosses creusées à même le sable
à l'orée du désert et on constate que
pendant le millénaire qui termine la
préhistoire égyptienne ces fausses vont
progressivement devenir de plus en plus
sophistiqués et vont se trouver
complexifier avec différentes fausse
annexe des forces qui ont des murs
maçonnés en brique crue c'est à dire en
briques simplement de terre séchée au
soleil
c'est construction en brique crue vont
être marqués le remplacement va être
marquée par un tumulus qui se trouve au
dessus de ces fausses vous avez de la
brique crue avec ici une reconstitution
bien entendu des éléments en bois donc
on est dans de l'architecturé fragile
qui permet de supporter une super
structure qui est au départ un simple
tumulus l'été qui va devenir un massif
réalisé en brique crue massifs réalisés
en brique crue que l'on appelle mastaba
d'un terme arabe qui est reçu en
archéologie égyptienne et qui signifie
une banquette maçonné est en fait l'idée
absolument innovante de jazz air va être
de reprendre cette structure millénaire
et non plus à réaliser en brique crue
mais de la réaliser en pierre et de
réaliser au dessus du lieu de son
enfouissement un massif un mastaba
gigantesque qui fait à peu près trente
mille mètres cubes de pierres c'est à
dire qu'il fait 63 mètres sur 63 m et
oui mètres de haut alors c'est la
première fois que les égyptiens s'essaye
à faire de l' architecture en pierre
sont donc quand même un peu prudents
même s'ils sont déjà très très audacieux
et eelv ont empilé ces pierres en les
inclinant vers le centre de l'édifice
pour assurer une meilleure stabilité à
l'édifice ce qui donne un bâtiment avec
des murs qui ont un fruit comme on
appelle cela en architecture c'est à
dire qui n'ont pas des murs verticaux
mais inclinée vers le centre de
l'édifice
lorsqu'on observe la maçonnerie de cet
édifice
on peut voir des traces des stigmates
que l'archéologie peut interpréter pour
suivre l'histoire de ce bâtiment
notamment des reprises de maçonnerie qui
permettent de suivre le fait que ce
bâtiment a été réalisé en cinq étapes
successives alors je propose de suivre
évidemment ces cinq étapes au tout
départ donc
jazz air à l'idée de se faire construire
un massif non plus en briques mais en
pierre de 63 mètres de côté et oui m 2
au 30 mille mètres cubes de pierres
c'est déjà très conséquent
il trouve l'idée manifestement superbe
et décide d'augmenter la masse de son
monument qui va marquer en fait l'esprit
de ses successeurs
donc ils augmentent tout d'abord la
masse une première fois
et puis une seconde fois notamment pour
ajouter des puits funéraire pour les
membres de sa famille cette augmentation
de la masse en superficie va devenir un
petit peu plus compliqué lorsqu'il
entame là
sainte qui entourent le monument de
djezzar une enceinte qui entoure un
complexe de 16 hectares donc ces
gigantesques avec une enfant qui
reproduit la façade du palais du roi à
l'époque qui était en matériaux
périssables qu'on reproduit donc en
pierre et qui fait 10 mètres cinquante
de haut alors vous avez vite fait le
calcul
une façade de 10 mètres cinquante de
haut avec un mastaba qui n'en fait que 8
vu de l'extérieur il est impossible en
fait de voir le monument funéraire du
pharaon ce qui est évidemment
inacceptable pour ce pharaon qui ne
manquaient de toute évidence pas
d'ambition ils exigent donc que on
augmente la hauteur de l'édifice
mais comment augmenter la hauteur d'un
édifice où vous n'êtes à une époque où
vous n'êtes pas sûr de pouvoir
construire des murs verticaux de plus de
10 mètres où vous avez peur et vous
incliner en fait les pierres les unes
contre les autres pour pouvoir mieux les
soutenir quelqu'un a eu l'idée leur
chèque temps chef du chantier a eu
l'idée absolument magistral de
reproduire en fait la même structure en
plus petit et de lampes il est sur la
structure précédente c'est-à-dire de
reproduire en fait 4 mastaba de même
forme mais de taille plus réduite pour
créer en réalité la première pyramide
c'est ainsi que les égyptiens ont créé
la première pyramide sans même s'en
rendre compte ils ont empilé 4 mastaba
les uns sur les autres de taille
dégressive pour pouvoir supporter en
fait cette élévation de l'architecturé
bien entendu le roi a trouvé le projet
formidable a décidé on va un cran plus
loin et ils ont transformé cette
structure en une structure à 6 degrés ou
si gradins qui est la pyramide que l'on
peut voir actuellement à saqqara qui
culmine à 60 mètres de hauteur alors
djezzar va passer aux yeux des anciens
égyptiens pour le pharaon qui a ouvert
l'ère de la pierre l'ère de la pierre
est très importante puisque c'est ce qui
marque en fait la culture pharaonique
nous sommes tous en pâmoison devant ces
monuments de pierre que la culture
égyptienne a produites et les égyptiens
qui visiteront ce monument pendant des
générations jusqu'à à l'époque des grecs
et des romains laisseront des
inscriptions en disant qu'ils viennent
visiter le monument de jazz air qui a
ouvert l'ère de la pierre c'est juste
lui le commanditaire
celui qui a eu l'idée géniale on le
connaît c'est son architecte il
s'appelle imhotep qui n'est pas une
momie dans un film contemporain qui est
un véritable architecte qui a réellement
existé
vingt-cinq siècles avant notre ère
qui était un grand partisan un proche de
jazz air qui est architecte en chef et
qui est aussi chef des sculpteurs qui
sera divinisé par la suite comme un
savant divin dans l'égypte narratif
alors je vous disais il ya un instant il
était aussi chef des sculpteurs c'est
très important parce que lorsque on
regarde d'un peu plus près cette
structure funéraire de jazz air on se
rend compte que il s'agit plus d'une
grande sculpture monumentale que d'une
véritable architecture en effet les
éléments de l'architecturé sont tous
sculptés dans la masse des murs savez
ici une porte devant vous voyez que les
goûts même de la porte sont sculptés
dans les pierres il est donc impossible
de les ouvrir au delà refermait c'est
une architecture en toc une architecture
factice et il en va de même pour tous
les éléments d'architecturé les colonnes
par exemple sont la pétrification la
conversion en pierre de colonne de
papyrus qui sont jumelés qui sont
ligaturer ensemble on a relié au mur par
départ des murs de refend parce qu'on
apport de soutenir la toiture sur des
simples colonnes on est au début de
l'architecturé de pierre évidemment et
même les dalles du plafond son dédale
qui sont sculptés sous la forme de
rondins de série de rondins qui sont
alignés qui sont même pas membres
donc l'idée est de faire une
architecture factice comme si on se
trouvait dans une architecture fragile
mais qui convertit en pierre et donc
c'est une sorte de sculpture qui imite
larchitecture réel en matériau fragile
lorsqu'on regarde donc ces bâtiments
c'est vraiment une architecture en toc
ça rappelle un peu larchitecture des
westerns de notre enfance ou même de
l'enfance de nos parents de l'époque de
john wayne
vous aviez en fait des grandes
palissades derrière lesquels il n'y
avait pas de maison ici en fait derrière
ces palissades sculpté vous avez des
massifs des maisons qui sont
complètement plein dans lesquels on ne
peut pas rentrer parce que ce décor de
western n'est pas destiné à des cowboys
elle est destinée aux fantômes du roi
qui par définition peut traverser les
murailles alors ce monument qui plus
sculptée en fait que architecture et qui
consiste en une architecture frein
factice il s'appuie en fait un nouveau
sur une longue tradition de travail de
la pierre qui remonte à la préhistoire
qui remonte au dernier millénaire de la
préhistoire égyptienne et procède à la
base d'une technique de forage au silex
de vases en pierre dure en effet on a
sur le site de saqqara toute une série
de blocs inachevé qui porte les
stigmates une fois de plus les stigmates
de leur réalisation des traces ici de
forage qui renvoie à cette technique de
vases en pierre dure que les égyptiens
précis à la fin de l'époque
préhistorique et qu'il creusait je vous
montre ici un vase qui est inachevée
vous avez exactement le même traces
d'érosion de la pierre qu'il creusait à
l'aide de forêt de silex sur une tige
lester vous en avez ici une
représentation de l'époque une tige
lester qui permettait de creuser en fait
la surface de la pierre c'est à partir
de cette longue tradition de creusement
des vases en pierre dure que les
égyptiens ont commencé à sculpter la
pierre et ont commencé à inventer en
fait l' architecture pour laquelle ils
sont aujourd'hui encore si célèbre alors
les égyptiens étaient parfaitement
conscients que c'est là que se trouve
l'origine de l'art de la pierre pour
lesquels ils sont si célèbre puisqu'ils
ont à partir de l'objet qui sert à
creuser ces vases créer un héros glyphes
aéro glyphes qui servent dans l'écriture
égyptienne à noter toutes les
productions et les fonctions liées aux
arts et aux artisanat il avait donc
eux-mêmes reconnu que l'origine du
travail de la pierre l'origine de leur
art résidait dans cette vieille
techniques préhistoriques de creusement
des vases de pierres alors le site de
saqqara l'invention de cette pyramide
sans même y penser en quelque sorte
constituent certes l'invention des
pyramides
ok mais c'est aussi en fait l'invention
de l'architecturé le même c'est
l'invention de l' architecture de pierre
larchitecture par rennes de l'
architecture tout court dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est donc
réellement une à une idée moonshot qui a
complètement changé le monde et à cette
époque on voit émerger en une seule fois
tout le vocabulaire architectural de
l'egypte antique toutes les formes
qu'ils vont rester dans l'architecturé j
piel avec ses colonnes floral qui sont
en fait la pétrification d'éléments de
l' architecture fragile et soit dit en
passant c'est idec les égyptiens aux
rues et s'est transmise à notre occident
puisque dans notre architecture même
contemporaine ici je vous montre
le bâtiment de la cour suprême à
washington dc qui imite larchitecture
grecque en fait l' architecture grecque
elle aussi possède une architecture
fragile avec des éléments végétaux ou en
briques de terre qui ont été pétrifiée
du jour au lendemain suivant ce principe
que les égyptiens ont eu l'idée géniale
d'inventer peut-être sans même s'en
rendre compte ou 27e siècle avant notre
ère et donc pour faire du neuf
ils ont en fait tout simplement revisité
l'ancien ils ont réinterprété leur
propre tradition en ne changeant qu'un
seul paramètre celui du matériau ils ont
ainsi donné naissance à une nouvelle
tradition qui continue encore
aujourd'hui et qui semble encore
aujourd'hui infinie celle de la
véritable architecture l'arrêt
l'invention le génie de l'opération
réside dans l'idée certes en apparence
un peu folle d'oser penser au delà des
limites de l'époque
il repose aussi faut bien le reconnaître
sur l'audace tout aussi folle d'un
pharaon qui ne manquaient de toute
évidence pas d'ambition et d'ego alors
pour réaliser un tel objectif il a été
très vite nécessaire de pouvoir
transporter de lourdes charges les
égyptiens ont été systématiquement
confrontés à cela et pour répondre à
cette nécessité
ils ont en fait déployer ils ont
exploité un principe extrêmement simple
pour vous le faire comprendre je vais
utiliser une petite anecdote de ma vie
personnelle
quand on est égyptologue on vous pose
toujours la même question lorsque vous
rencontrer les gens et donc lors d'une
réunion de famille j'ai rencontré une
petite cousine par alliance que je ne
connaissais pas qui m'a demandé des
égyptologues tu peux m'expliquer la
construction des pyramides je n'avais
pas les 18 minutes d'intox
j'ai dit comment ce que je vais faire
j'ai constaté qu à côté d'elle il y
avait un gros coffre
je lui ai dit ce gros coffre tu ne
pourrais pas le soulever mais tu peux le
déplacer en le poussant avec tes jambes
ou avec ton corps c'est exactement ce
que les égyptiens ont fait donc en fait
ils ont compris qu'il est beaucoup plus
difficile et beaucoup plus périlleux de
louvres levée des charges lourdes que de
les pousser ou de les tirer
et donc ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils
ont poussé ou tirer les charges en
essayant d'éviter au maximum de les
soulever alors comme les égyptiens ne
connaissait pas la roue et vous voyez
d'après mon exposé qu en fait des
égyptiens sont loin d'avoir inventé la
roue il ne connaissait pas la roue ils
ont donc utilisé sur un plan
technologique 1 j'entends ils ont donc
utilisé en fait des traîneaux qui
permettait de tirer ses lourdes charges
sur le sol le problème
résoudre était celui de la réduction du
coefficient de frottement sur le sol
mais là aussi ils avaient une astuce
puisque c'est raynaud qui sont attestés
que logiquement qu'ils sont attestés
iconographique mans dans les
représentations
on voit en fait comment ils les ont
utilisés vous avez ici un traîneau sous
une statue colossale est en fait
systématiquement dans ses
représentations
vous avez un personnage qui mouille le
sol devant le traîneau en fait ils se
sont rendus compte que le limon du nil
la terre que charrie la crue du nil
chaque année est extrêmement glissant
lorsqu'elle est mouillée et des
expériences d'archéologie expérimentale
au début du siècle dernier ont permis de
montrer car normalement constitué est
capable de déplacer sur ce genre de
traîneau est sûre du leem ont mouillé un
bloc d'une tonne sans effort particulier
donc c'est pour vous montrer
l'efficacité de cette idée à nouveau
extrêmement simple alors pour élever les
blocs
ils ont utilisé aussi une technique
extrêmement rudimentaires qui est connu
à travers toute l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est celle des rampes
ils ont construit ces rendre que l'on
trouve en réalité sur tous les chantiers
inachevés d'architecturé gip sienne tout
des chantiers inachevés ou on a ces
rampes réalisé avec les déchets de
construction du monument et chaque fois
recouverte de limon pour pouvoir faire
monter les blocs y compris sur les sites
de pyramides où elles sont bien attestée
vous avez ici un exemple en
reconstitution autres stigmates
archéologiques qui nous permet de
comprendre comment ces pyramides ont été
faites les marques de carrier en heroes
cliff hanger griffe simplifier les
marques de carrier et les marques des
équipes d'ouvriers les égyptiens étaient
très procédurier y noter
l'administration de tout ça ça nous
permet en fait de reconstitueurs c'est
précisément l'organisation logistique du
travail avec différentes équipes et on
peut constater que ces équipes viennent
des quatre coins du territoire égyptien
et donc les pyramides ne sont pas
l'oeuvre d'esclaves comme on a souvent
voulu le croire
et certainement pas des esclaves hébreux
qui n'existe absolument pas à cette
époque c'est une oeuvre nationale
réalisée par des ouvriers libre qui
étaient payés en nature est sans doute
très fiers de participer à l'oeuvre de
leur époque de participer à la décision
au monument commandité par pharaon qui
je vous le rappelle est conçu comme une
sorte de dieu sur terre
à l'époque derniers détails à propos de
l'organisation logistique du
travail de la masse ouvrière le site de
guiza où se trouvent les deux plus
grandes pyramides de l'histoire
égyptienne la pyramide de khéops la
pyramide de khéphren a livré les restes
d'un camp d'ouvriers les ouvriers qui
ont travaillé à la réalisation de ces
monuments et la fouille de ce campement
a permis de montrer qu'il s'agit en fait
d'un campement destiné à accueillir
jusqu'à 18 mille ouvriers
évidemment quand vous avez 18 mille
ouvriers sous la main vous pouvez
commencer à penser large à penser aux à
penser grand à penser moonshot au delà
des limites
alors vous le voyez en somme il n'y a
pas de secret il n'y a pas de mystère
technologique
il n'y a pas de technique mystérieuse
qui aurait été apportée d'ailleurs par
des extraterrestres que sais-je ce sont
des techniques extrêmement rudimentaire
c'est une technologie presque
ridiculement simple que les égyptiens
ont utilisé est le véritable secret
réside dans une organisation de la force
de travail tout à fait remarquable
alors c'est un cas d' idée folle qui a
changé le monde dans la lointaine
histoire qui nous rappelle je pense deux
choses la première c'est que la
civilisation émergent de l'organisation
sociale et c'est ainsi qu'elle peut
réaliser de grandes choses des choses
qui défie l'entendement comme la seule
des sept merveilles du monde antique qui
subsistent encore droite
de nos jours comme le dit notre devise
nationale en belgique l'union fait la
force
les égyptiens l'avait bien compris et
dernière chose que ces pyramides nous
rappelle en tant que idée moonshot c'est
que comme les égyptiens en était
parfaitement convaincu dans l'antiquité
pour aborder le présent et l'avenir
il est souvent bien utile de se
retourner de chercher dans le passé
une source d'inspiration car revisiter
le passé avec un regard actuel est
souvent à mieux envisager l'avenir